new media rockstars
so happy to be here at the
uh what's trending does this every year
and it's so great to see the youtube
community come together
to benefit a charity i think this year
it's covenant house and so hopefully we
can make a difference it sounds like
halo the people that are going to kill
everyone
covered in house are you going to be
doing any kind of performances or
anything tonight are you just hanging
out and joining the budget from what i
know i'm in line
talking to santa and then they're going
to do a little interview with me so i'm
trying to think of my bit still i got to
try to think of something funny but i
don't have anything planned it's going
to be off the cuff we'll see what
happens well i think i'm on stage i'm
introducing someone and then i think
there's like a segment with me and
christina horner where we're gonna be
talking and doing something cool so are
you gonna be performing or you're just
mingling and enjoying the crowd um i'm
going to be live tweeting i have a
segment to do live tweeting tonight so
i'm looking forward to that i'm hosting
like the tweet center
so i don't know i'm like standing with
shira and acting like an idiot i'm
presenting tonight so yeah i'm thinking
i'm one of the first ones up i'm really
excited about it me and steve green are
introducing a performer travis garland
tonight and uh we're you know going for
charity
so yeah i'm helping to present something
i think we're hanging out in the tweet
room reading tweets you got the tweet
that will be wild and crazy i'm sure
because you never know what people are
going to say they're i might get
completely nude and get weird back there
right we're usually pretty good yeah
we're pretty good at that it's all for
charity what are you doing for christmas
this year what am i doing for christmas
this year i'm going back to visit my
family in colorado okay very excited
about that yeah i'm planning to see my
girlfriend's family we're gonna stay
there for like a week and then fly back
here and do my stuff get ready film more
videos and stuff like that so um i'm
going back home going to philly to see
my family i'm really excited nothing
really crazy
i mean my family's kind of crazy but
other than that yeah i'm just going to
go snowboarding in tahoe and uh i got
injured last year so now i wear a helmet
so that's where i'm at in my life i'm a
helmet guy yeah so i'm going to put my
helmet on and snowboard down the
mountain and and feel like a young man
again do you have any crazy cool
christmas plans
yes i'm doing a christmas concert for my
uncle and my mom in the living room so
it's going to be a really big event it's
going to be pretty huge so i'm really
excited about that
and i'm just waiting to see what i'm
going to get from santa so um you know i
was thinking about like i don't know
getting a tree or like uh then like
maybe i don't know like i was thinking
like maybe like ornaments and like like
wrapping paper this year i was thinking
about like taking presents
wrapping them in shiny paper putting
bows on them and giving them to people i
don't know i'm crazy you know what
christmas is the time to like chill out
and stop the violence
you know santa's like a peaceful guy and
like whatever else you believe in is
probably also a peaceful thing
um so yeah i'm just gonna hang out and
uh you know what maybe take advantage of
like the off time and like bottle up
some videos or something yeah man i'm
gonna bake so many pumpkin pies like
crazy and pumpkin pie isn't even a
christmas type of pie it's meant for
thanksgiving so favorite holiday uh yeah
so lock me up you know with what's
trending we look at all the things that
we loved growing up and all the formats
and shows you say how can we do this for
the youtube generation and the digital
audience and so for this we wanted to
create something that brings everyone
together for the holidays of celebration
instead of just a party how it would
create something that's entertaining
that everyone can watch live our
community our fans and also give back
for the holidays because all of us do so
many different separate things but we do
one thing
once a year that brings the whole entire
youtube community together all the
different youtube networks and also give
back so we believe it's important in
coming house this is the second year
that we're raising money for them and
we're lucky enough to have forward in
the fiesta movement donating a dollar
per hashtag fiesta movement hashtag
tubathon to the charity uh which you
couldn't ask for more so it's a really
exciting event last year we did it in
our what's trending studio which is a
very cute point spot this year youtube
space la opened up their doors for us
multiple stages i mean we have we were
probably like 20 talent or so last year
we had like 100 talents
and so it's just bigger and better and
and yeah and i mean i think the
community has also grown so much since
so we have better talent uh we have
people joining in from around the world
so overall this is like it's growing so
hopefully it'll be even bigger next year
and it'll continue to be something we do
every single year
toby how's it going tonight fantastic
how are you jeff i am excellent good to
see you makes use of the name tag
literacy
fantastic no i mean personally i want
like inner peace cats and like beautiful
stuff like um
birthday cake oreos ah here we go
we need an action shot
that one was even better i liked it
oh my gosh no not at all have you been
good or bad this year i've been really
good i'm not a sinner so no porn here
somebody knows me yeah yeah right you
kind of wander in the carpet like
somebody took my picture please oh there
you go a feisty
i like it